[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show this is where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
Rachel Cruz number one best-selling
author Ramsay personality my daughter is
my co-host today as we take your
questions about your life and your money
the phone number triple eight eight two
five five two two five the call is free
and some say the advice is worth exactly
what you pay for it Dan starts off this
hour in Tampa hi Dan welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey Dave how you doing today better than
I deserve what's up
hey
um thanks for taking my call Rachel nice
to hear from you as well
um I wanted to give a call today my wife
and I
um we got married last year and um
recently we've saved up enough money to
purchase our first home uh currently we
have saved
um more than five percent and even 20
down for a home so my biggest question
today is is it a good idea to start and
maybe do five or ten percent to start as
you know the world is in a very
interesting place and also is it still a
good time to buy a house I know that you
mentioned back in June or July then then
was the best time to buy a house and so
I want to make sure I'm a good husband
and a good Steward of my money and I
would just love some feedback and wisdom
of that
Dan you're such a good guy just so
mature I just I just appreciate the
thoughtfulness already
um you know when it comes to to buying a
home overall kind of the principle that
I always say is to make sure that you're
the one that's ready to buy the home and
it's not necessarily what the market is
doing right it could be a great market
and you could be broke and it would be
devastating for you or it could not be a
great Market but you financially have
the money that you're able to jump in
and you're like you know why not let's
just do it right so like there's
where you are Dan financially is the
most important thing and so everything
that you've laid out so far I'm assuming
you have no debts and an emergency fund
on top of the down payment is that
correct
um so with the we do have a five
thousand dollar car payment it's like 75
per month okay two percent interest so
that's the only thing currently how much
do you have how much do you have in
Savings in savings is that with like my
everything or everything oh we're
talking probably over 110. write a check
today and pay off your car
okay okay now you're debt free because
you don't qualify to buy a house until
then it under Ramsey rules okay because
we don't want broke people buying houses
because when broke people buy houses it
makes them broker and when you got a car
payment you're broke people okay so now
you're now you don't have a car payment
anymore we just got rid of that we need
to allocate three to six months of
expenses of your money to the side for
your rainy day fund
okay that's all set okay and then in
addition to those two things the five
thousand and the six months how much do
you have to put down in the house
after I took five thousand of your
dollars
so what I mean taking out say it was 110
we'd be at 105. my biggest question no
no how much is it how much of that's the
emergency fund
oh the emergency fund's about 30 grand
of that 100.
yes okay so now we have 75
yep okay that's what we've got to work
with 75 000 great now what's your
household income
uh household income annually uh before
taxes is 180. okay way to go what do
y'all do
uh I am an account executive for a
construction software company and my
wife works uh as a customer success
manager for a CRM company well you guys
are just like a power couple man look at
you way to go good money good stuff
you're doing a smart things way to go
way to go so uh yeah then you start
looking and saying yes I'm going to buy
a home now if you think that the world
is so topsy-turvy that you need to hoard
cash then you don't need to buy a house
so you need to put 75 000 down on a
house smile get you a nice house 15-year
fixed for the payments no more than a
fourth year take-home pay and if you're
not willing to plunk the 75 000 down on
that house don't buy a house
okay because it tells me that you think
the world's too crazy to be a homeowner
well and the the interest rates are
higher right Dan then and that's what a
lot of people are looking at as they are
either first-time home buyers or buying
and so like oh my gosh interest rates
but here's the deal you can refinance
when the rates drop which they will
eventually they're not going to stay
this High forever so you can't always
refinance
yeah so put the 75 down the rate Mary
the home right exactly exactly so my
question is on that is
um to be completely Frank we're in our
due diligence period we put an offer in
our house it's been accepted we've
negotiated
um it is in Georgia Tampa has been a
great time but it's just been very very
expensive
um and just did a community as well but
I'm necessarily not scared of the market
um but I I have people in my family that
are very skeptical and thinking that I'm
making a larger mistake and I don't want
yeah that's called being like a grown-up
and married you make your own decisions
stuff
yeah I mean it's sweet that people have
an opinion about your life they love you
and and how old are you precious how old
are you
I'm 24. okay so listen Dan this could be
like kind of like Dave is saying I'll
say in a nicer way that your first
decision that you're gonna make that
people in your life are like ooh that
you're not being wise so automatically
Dan yeah 24 you haven't had the life
experience in the years and the muscle
to built to be able to stand really
securely to say no no I've done the math
this is what we believe and we're going
to go forward right this is the first
pushback so it's going to feel
uncomfortable you're going to question
yourself the first time your parents do
question you as an adult you're thinking
oh gosh am I making a bad mistake right
so getting wisdom from people and all of
that I think is is great but what you
have to understand is you've done the
work you've run the numbers you're
working a plan that you believe and that
way teacher at Ramsay that millions of
people have done and they've been okay
and they've won with money so you're not
doing anything crazy or that's gonna you
know that that's somehow gonna sink you
financially so I would say it's gonna
feel uncomfortable but once you go
against what your parents think over and
over and have your own opinions over and
over it gets easier right are you
looking at me
the grown child
it gets easier the grown child that had
never had any issue voicing her opinion
since she was four so there we go okay
oh you're going to be dropping down it
may have something to do with your mama
don't want you to move to Georgia too it
could you know they could come up into
it so
um and we're going to use the economy as
an excuse to keep you around in case you
make a grandbaby so um there's all kinds
of stuff can weave into these things so
what you've got to do is do exercise the
muscle muscle of being kind to those who
care about you but don't get a vote
and it's just like that sweet that's
precious thank you for your input
um and we're gonna go do whatever the
flip we want to do anyway so
Sharon and I do a pretty good job uh as
uh parents and in-laws uh yes you're not
voicing our opinion unless we're asked
now if you ask you know now you don't
open the door kind of like when you call
this show right but uh but if you don't
ask I just got to stand back and watch
you and grin and go nah it's gonna leave
a mark
[Music]
what just happened a time or two yeah no
I mean it's it may not leave them or I
might be wrong but I don't we just don't
interfere unless we're out we don't
matter of fact we don't do that with
anybody with our friends I had a friend
the other day stupid he pulled up my
driveway to show me his new lease car
and I'm like you know well that's nice
it's a nice car
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsay today
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
your life and your money hey we've got
an entree leadership theme hour coming
up and what that means is we'll be
answering your small business questions
what's your current pain point with your
business your team
managing the finances
marketing questions
oh there's all kinds of things going on
in business these days it's a
complicated little world out there so
send your questions to ask at
ramsesolutions.com entree theme hour ask
ramseysolutions.com February 13th I have
taken over the entree leadership podcast
where I answer your I we change the
format I'm going to be answering your
business questions callers calling in on
the podcast and so if you want to
participate in that just check out the
Ontario leadership podcast again the
February 13th version will begin with me
answering your questions I'm having a
blast doing those and so basically it's
a
a a small business theme hour uh once a
week on entree podcast with me answering
the questions so in addition to the one
we're gonna be doing here on the Ramsay
show so they're everywhere they're
everywhere so be sure and jump in with
us ask if you want to do any question
for that matter if you want to just
email us in the team will get back to
you we'll try to get you on the air here
or on entree wherever you need to be on
deloney show you can we can get you
there man I'm telling you ask at
ramsesolutions.com especially for an
entree leadership theme hour that's what
the big push there is so thanks for
joining us Natasha's in Canada hi
Natasha welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey thank you for having me sure what's
up
um well first off I want to say thank
you for giving a soon-to-be single mom
from Hope
um
I thought I was going to be screwed but
now I'm not so I my question is about
investing
um I'm in Canada and I'm brand new to
this uh brand new to your methods and I
everything that I've looked at online
has everything to do with investing in
the states and I was wondering if it
translates to Canada as well
well fairly similarly as far as the
investing part the principles are common
sense and biblical principles so getting
out of debt that translates anywhere
right
um living on less than you make that
translates anywhere you've got to do
those types of things everywhere
regardless now as far as using the
Ramsay baby steps uh you know as you
said you can find out about those online
a lot of different ways to get that and
there's seven baby steps and walking up
through the majority of those will work
anywhere until you get to the investing
part and then you've got to use you know
we're talking about it in the states
401ks and Roth IRAs which doesn't apply
in uh you know in England in Australia
we've got a lot of listeners there uh
and certainly in Canada we've got a ton
of listeners so and viewers so anyway to
answer the question once you get there
you you know baby step one's a thousand
dollars two is your emergency fund three
is an uh our two is be debt free except
your home three is a fully funded
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses babysat Force fifteen percent
of your income going into retirement
five is start saving for kids college uh
six would be pay off your home early
those would stay in place then how you
would do fifteen percent of your income
into retirement you've got a Canadian
retirement program correct
yes but sorry I guess I should clarify
the question is more so finding the
different than going because you have
your smart investor Pros right and I
can't find any SMART bus or Pros in
Canada
uh there's because because of
regulations uh Canadian regs are
completely different than America so uh
we're not able to do an endorsement of
financial uh stock Brokers uh so to
speak uh and investment advisors in
Canada but here's what the principle you
would use you're looking for someone
with the heart of a teacher yeah so
Natasha's sitting down with someone in
this industry I would say like any any
industry in life you're going to have
people that are kinds that are patients
that are willing to help you in your
situation willing to teach you and
you're going to feel that sitting down
with that type of person or you're going
to sit down and feel gross and the
person is slimy and you're like I don't
have a good feeling about this so trust
your guts because they're arrogant yes
so you want to be sitting down and
hiring someone who again has a heart of
a teacher so it's it's really feeling
the spirit off of them and hey are they
willing to walk with me and teach me and
that's the kind of person that you want
to work with not someone who is
intimidating that you're scared to ask
questions and that just feels gross you
know those kind of people Natasha we all
have that you have that gut check where
you're like oh I don't this doesn't feel
right just listen to that so inner so go
I would interview ask around even for
you know your friends and family and
just say hey do you guys use anyone that
you trust that you love interview maybe
three to four different people and just
kind of get a feel for what they're like
how they're explaining things to you and
then choose someone because I would I
would really recommend yeah having
someone on your side who does this day
in and day out I think that's really
really important but the big mistake
with things that are intimidating or
that we don't understand is to just turn
it over to someone blindly and say well
I've got me a guy
and this is how people lose all their
money
all right and so uh you're responsible
for your money not the guy
he's responsible to teach you our gal he
or she is responsible to teach you
so you can make decisions if they do not
have the heart of a teacher they will
instead have the heart of a Salesman and
they'll be a level of arrogance there'll
be a transactional feel rather than a
relational feel to the meeting to
Rachel's point and uh you run out of
there and you get your different one
Natasha are you at that point for
investing do you have any your debt free
savings
I will be within the next few months
um we're looking at call like I'm
looking at moving out and within about
five months kind of thing and at that
point I should be able to organize
everything so that I can start off okay
and are you
um because at the beginning of the call
you said you're a single mama is that a
more recent thing in your life
it's going to be yes so it will be told
my common law partner of 13 years at
Christmas that or just after Christmas
that I was done trying to fight and well
you know the kids school year that we
were going to drive separate ways wow
I'm so sorry and you know what Natasha
it would be okay to pause you know don't
make a huge financial decision
uh in the midst of the cleaning up
cleaning up your debt will give you
stability you don't need to pause that
but pausing the investing decisions yeah
don't forget you're really part of
recovering from a relationship uh split
up is to get your confidence back
I'm working on that now yeah and so make
sure you got that back because that
melds into the advice we just gave you
because
um you know I like a few years ago I had
this lawyer this that was working for me
um as a lawyer not on my staff but I
decided he was going to tell me how we
were going to do stuff and I went nah
man you're confused I write you checks
I tell you stuff you don't tell me stuff
arrogant twerp and so I had plenty of
confidence to run him off because he
decided he was going to be you know I'm
supposed to do what he says because he's
got a law degree which means absolutely
nothing and so I do want to learn from
him about the law and about the
situation and then I'll make the
decision but you're not going to dictate
to me because I'm confident in that and
you need to be in that kind of a
position not arrogant but confident that
you know confidence in yourself and I
trust my own instincts and I'm going to
learn from this person and then I'll
make the decision based on the knowledge
transfer and that's their job and if
they can't do their job you need a
different one yeah for sure so yeah
Natasha I would
um
pay off the debt get some Savings in
place and and again one year of not
investing or six months you're you're
fine I would really just be patient with
it because you're you're going through I
mean there's going to be there's gonna
be a lot that you're about to walk
through and it's really hard really
really after 13 years and if you guys
have kids together I mean it's just
um it's hard it's a yeah it's a lot so
don't feel like you have to rush into
something like investing but I I am
kudos to you though that you're
researching and figuring out a plan and
you know getting to this point that
you're like okay I'm gonna be doing this
so
um so that that's that's amazing if
you're a new listener or a new viewer
like she is Hey listen if you go to
ramseysolutions.com you can click the
get started button get started button
and it'll help you get to the next step
in your financial Journey it'll show you
what those baby steps are we're talking
about some of this lingo we throw around
here on the show is all over the place
it's kind of inside baseball almost so
you can start to learn the lingo of the
stuff we're talking about the get that
started but it's completely free it's an
assessment that'll tell you where you
are and then what your next steps are
and we'll help you we're going to walk
with you it's what we do completely free
ramseysolutions.com click the get
started button and if you're right where
she is then you'll get to move on to the
next step or be prepared to move for the
next step this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
Rising learn how Christian Healthcare
Ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
foreign
[Music]
Cruise Ramsay personality is my co-host
today number one best-selling author
Paul is with us Paul's in Washington D.C
hey Paul welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey Dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up um I have a question I've been
saving for college expenses with a 529
and now I'm in a position where I'm
ready to use it my daughter's in college
uh but it's losing value it's been
losing value based on the last year and
I'm wondering if I should kind of ride
this out before withdrawing from 529 or
how would you pay for it withdrawal
I'm sorry how would you pay for college
so I'm in a fortunate position that I
could actually pay so I have my
emergency fund that I could pay the cash
and then kind of ride it out to see how
the year plays out
an emergency fund
yeah so I I have savings you know I mean
there's a difference in savings and
emergency fund your emergency fund is
three to six months of expenses anything
beyond that is just liquid cash we could
use that but I'm not touching your
actual emergency fund
not an emergency you got some extra cash
beyond your emergency fund I think
yes yeah that is correct you're sitting
on a pile of money how much money is in
this pile
I wouldn't say it's a pile but yeah how
much money how much 60 60 000 okay how
much of that is your emergency fund
uh forty two thousand okay so we got 18
000 we can play and give the market a
little bit time to heal
yep so that's probably not a whole year
of college
Center Paul
I'm fortunate that I have uh grants
um so it's around 9 000 a semester okay
so that'd be two semesters of tuition
only she's living at home
no okay then it's one semester of money
18 000 is going to be gone in one
semester
right am I missing something with 9 000
of living expenses you think well I mean
it you don't have enough to make it two
semesters yeah yeah whatever it is so
you're gonna you know after you you get
how much you get the delay touching your
529 18 000 worth whatever that is right
so yes I would do that but no I would
not touch your emergency fund no I would
not take out a student loan to time the
market
gotcha how much is in the 529
uh the 529 has 58 000 in it 58. now how
are you paying for the rest of school
yep
yep that's what I'm working on
I mean I'm just saving for it
okay what's your household income sir
uh it's about 210 000 a year okay you'll
make it you're gonna make it you'll be
okay yeah so and if you got 58 000 of
the 529 that means an actual cash you
did not lose much because the Market's
not down but about 10 percent
right so I mean you lost like five grand
or something it's not like this I know
I'm kind of tempted I mean I would be
curious what you'd say just to go ahead
and you I mean the 529 is there why
would you I would call it on waiting for
18 000 worth though let the market you
would just take all that cat all his
cash that down to an emergency fund sure
sure he's gonna use it anyway
eventually plus 18 is not enough to go
to college I know but I'm just thinking
between now and 12 months if he needs
that cash for replace a car or you know
what I mean they're doing it they're not
gonna have it for a call I mean it it
that money's going to college his kid's
going to school so yeah that money's
gone it's earmarked you just hadn't
realized it until this conversation
right right right uh you don't get to
buy a car if your kid's going to college
you're going to be driving that car
because you're going to need that money
18 plus 58 I know plus cash flows income
is barely going you can do it but
there's no squeeze room here yeah so uh
you're doing a good job let me tell you
Paul you are like 98 ahead of everybody
that's right because most people talk
about stuff and do nothing and you have
done something you have saved money you
have a 529 lots of good positive things
going on there very very very well done
very well done I'm proud of you so good
stuff thanks for letting us work through
that with you uh by the way folks the
Biden Administration has signed the
secure act 2.0 two issues in there that
are pretty cool about student loans if
you have an over funded not Paul's
problem an overfunded 529 and you don't
use it all for school 15 years later
you're now allowed to roll it to a Roth
IRA with no penalties
and so uh if the kid could not the
parent because they're not in the
parent's name it's in the kid's name so
if his daughter had 158 000 in that 529
and there's 40 000 left over after she
graduates used to be kind of stuck in
there now they're going to allow you
after 15 years she can roll it that's a
really nice feature yeah that the Biden
Administration in the Congress got
through I make fun of both of them odd
infinitum uh but I'll just great job
I'll tip my hat to both of them I don't
know who came up with the idea but Biden
signed it so we'll give everybody a
little credit up there that was actually
good work uh to encourage that the
second thing is now employers can uh put
up to three thousand dollars into your
401k matching your student loan payments
so if you pay down through your student
loans by three thousand dollars your
employer now can add a benefit to their
benefits package and put up to three
thousand dollars into your 401k now that
three thousand dollars not gonna change
your life that's more every yearly every
year annually once a year yeah but we're
not going to wait around and do this and
we're not going to uh keep the student
loan in order to get that oh geez that's
the problem with stuff like that I know
all the unattended consequences but just
some sidebar with what Paul's talking
about there so good job Paul well done
proud of you my man Andrew's in Atlanta
what's up Andrew
hey Dave uh thanks for taking my call
yeah so my wife and I we recently bought
a house last year
um we're currently on baby step six
already so we're feeling really good
about that uh you helped us get get here
which is great
um but we've we've kind of had some as
as what happens when you buy a new house
we have lots of maintenance for things
that have come up
um Unfortunately they weren't really
covered in the original purchasing
agreement so we kind of have to pay it
out of pocket and um we're at the point
where we're having to start dipping into
our emergency fund or delaying some of
the repairs in this case a leaking roof
and I know that my wife's really
hesitant about ever dipping into our
emergency fund so I'd love to come I
like your wife your input
I'd love to get your input on like you
know when when is it okay to to kind of
dip into that emergency fund if it means
that you know we can kind of fix the
leaks right now we have a tarp on the
roof and
um I know she just it's her last resort
you know uh how much is in the emergency
fund
above 36 000. 36 how much would the roof
be
uh the roof would be about um ten
thousand dollars but we have about four
thousand dollars set aside to cover um
that we've been able to kind of put
together in the last month or so so you
would take six out of the emergency fund
that's correct and that would be worst
case we're getting other um your
household income is what
about 250 000 a year and so you could
pay for the roof next month
um we could but we also have like the
mortgage payment and that would kind of
I
a month
the next couple of months planned out
ahead of
fix your plan change your roof leaked
right and that's kind of where I'm at
and I know that like you know we kind of
have these money set aside for this
purpose and and you know we don't really
want to touch it but at some point like
you know that's what that money's for no
no not if you can cash flow it
um okay you know it's an emergency if
you can't cover it any other way
and so because here's the thing okay
let's say you did the roof this month
four and six out of the emergency fund
you know what you got to do in the next
two months
go out to eat let the emergency fund
back
right so it's kind of like you got to do
it next month anyway
so it's just swapping dollars from the
right pocket of the left pocket because
it's just such a short time frame
you're either going to put the money
back in the emergency fund next month or
you're going to do the roof next month
still their little plan that you had
laid out screwed because the roof leaked
yeah sorry I mean
I mean roof leak I really am I've been
through that it's no fun so I I you know
it doesn't matter to me whenever you can
get the best deal and get the roofer
lined up and get everything done make
sure the leak isn't causing other damage
I mean this may be more courageous it
makes the HOA happy because everybody
just loves the blue tarp look
makes everybody the neighborhood's going
up I mean we got the blue tarps in the
neighborhood now so trying to stay out
of the emergency department
fifty thousand dollars a year and I got
a blue tarp
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
well Valentine's Day is coming
Valentine's Day you know Winston I do we
celebrate on the 13th because that's
when we got engaged and we skip all the
hysteria of the 14th so well you get a
you can get a restaurant reservation too
I know and it's not like a set menu and
all that yeah you get around it get
around it but uh I know a lot of people
out there you guys celebrate Valentine's
Day you know the the holiday of love and
it's more important than ever to focus
on your relationships the relationships
in your life specifically if you're
married so when it comes to Valentine's
Day we are all about deepening your
relationships and we have a great way to
do that with questions for humans which
is a conversation cards by Dr John
deloney so this is for parents and kids
this is for couples the workplace
friends or the dating scene so every
question will have you laughing together
learning something unexpected and
building deeper and stronger
relationships so don't just get
chocolate and a card and all the
stereotypical stuff you know get
something that you actually will learn
about the people in your life that you
love so make sure to check out questions
for humans at ramseysolutions.com humans
now the first two and a half weeks of
February at our house my wife Sharon is
Sharon palusa
that's right because our first date was
February 6th her birthday's the eighth
and Valentine's Day the 14th so it's
just like it just keeps the hits they
just keep on coming so we just set the
side the first two weeks it's all about
her February as if it's not all about
her to start with but um anyway all
right let's go to Travis in Austin Texas
hey Travis welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Mr Ramsey how are you better than I
deserve sir what's up
so over the course of the last five
years I've really kind of gotten my
financial
um house in order and I've put together
what I feel is you know a pretty good
amount of money and
I I've been a long time listener I'm a
first-time caller and I haven't paid off
my house
how much money and I have what was that
how much money
um my total net worth is
it's probably about 850 Grand and you
said I put together a pretty good amount
of money how much are that 850 is money
550 to 600 000 okay and how much of
that's in retirement
000. okay you got three or four hundred
thousand non-retirement laying around
you owe what on your house
235 000 okay she got the cash to pay it
off without touching retirement did I
get that right
yes sir okay so what's your question
well I I'm in the middle of I'm thinking
about moving away from my house and and
getting another house
um because of I want my kids in a
different school and so you know do I go
pay off this house rent it out buy
another one because I have the cash to
do both and I'm just kind of paralyzed
because uh I grew up poor so cash was
kind of King right you you have it in
the bank and it looks really nice but
it's not really doing anything for me
good point and it's a scary it's a scary
thing to
go from
not not house broke but all of a sudden
all your money's in the house
yeah you can't get to it yeah
exactly yes there's some comfort from
being able to lay your hands on it I
don't disagree with that I understand
that so here's the thing you're gonna
move
yes okay we're gonna pay cash for that
house can we agree with that much
for the house that I'm going to move
into yeah you want your home but you
want your home paid for yeah enough of
this okay so your home's paid for now
now then the only question is the rest
of the money do we want to tie it up in
a rental property or do we want to put
it in mutual funds
yes sir which one
rental property or mutual funds
I would tie it up in rental property but
you can't get to it as easy as you can
in a mutual fund
yes sir and I think because of my job
situation I'm not as concerned about
meeting it immediately
um it's a different conversation who's
the guy I was talking to a few minutes
ago
well you I think you can understand this
it feels good when you can look on your
phone you know how much money is in your
bank right I don't disagree with you
that's why I'm asking these questions
I'm just helping you walk through it so
if I'm in your shoes I'm paying cash for
my personal residence and then the extra
money is either going to be invested in
real estate that's paid for with no
mortgage or it's going to be invested in
mutual funds this is what we teach you
know that you've been listening to us
yes sir Travis I know you said you want
to move either one's okay
yeah and you want to move houses because
you want a better school system for your
kids is that right
yes yes so are you so with that when
you're looking at the new area that
you're moving to is all of this does
that sound reasonable to sell the house
you're in take the cash you have
and buy a house yeah
no um so because of where I'm at I'm
outside of Austin and the real estate
market here has just been great for
forever I I you know I owe 235 on my
house I could probably sell my house
because I've renovated it for 500 000
and or more and so it's like well if I
pay off that I can rent that out and I
can apply that to a new house
still afford a conventional loan and
then put the money from that into the
new house nope
nope no nope listen if your new home was
paid for
and you didn't own any rental property
would you go borrow a mortgage on it to
buy a rental property no
no same thing
taking out a mortgage to keep from
getting rid of the one that's paid for
right nope and Travis you're playing
you're playing the the math game and I
hear that right we hear this all the
time I could do this and that and swap
that and that but but what you're
wanting and especially what you said a
few minutes ago about how I grew up and
I just went cash into like you want this
level of security Travis and I'm telling
you when you have no debt when you have
no debt on your home and there is
there's no payments in the world that
freedom that autonomy that level of
relaxing in your spirit is something
that you're looking for and I think that
that's going to give you a deeper level
of satisfaction than trying to play this
rental property game of taking a
mortgage you know keeping this house
getting a mortgage on the new I mean
you're shuffling around which
mathematically again this is what the
financial world we hear this all the
time and I get it right you look it on
paper but what you're missing is this
underlying piece of having deep deep
peace when it comes to your money and I
think you're gonna feel a level of
Freedom when you have no payment so
you're going to make different decisions
I think I think I messed up the numbers
early in the conversation or uh Travis I
Thought I understood you could pay for
both houses in cash and I don't think
you can is that what you're telling me
uh not with not with my wife I can't
not the house that you want no oh that's
what I meant okay so that meant that
means that means the house that you're
that you're living in is going to be
sold
okay yes sir and I I took that out of
the conversation and okay I
misunderstood you don't get the option
of the real estate versus mutual fund
you're selling the house that you're in
you're going to pay cash with the
proceeds from that house and then cash
you have in the bank for the new house
and what Rachel's saying then is going
to kick in because the borrower is slave
to the lender and when you are free of
Masters in your life
the only master in your life is Jesus
then you don't have
the stress you don't have the and hey
dude you make a lot of money and you've
done really good you're really smart and
so what will happen is without a payment
in the world you're going to pile up
money so fast that you're gonna have
great Investments going again and maybe
even go pay cash for a rental later
but for now let's get into the personal
residence that set your family up you've
worked hard for that pay cash for it by
selling the other house and combining
the free non-retirement cash with that
to get there and you can do that and
then let's use that increased cash flow
and increased peace
at home with your wife your kid is in
the school system what a great dad um
and what a great provider you just
you're just Manning up in a culture
that's completely forgotten how to do
that so proud of you so good good man
and that that's the route you go and
then without a house payment and with
your income you're gonna have another
million dollars so fast it's going to be
blinding to you you're gonna look back
and go I can't believe I was worried
about that because that's the way it's
going to go down I really it's the way
it's going to go down great job Travis
way to go Travis but please go that
route don't try to do too many things at
once let's take a step at a time step at
a time be the tortoise don't be the hair
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships
thank you for being with us America
Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality is my
co-host today number one best-selling
author and my daughter the phone number
here is triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five Rachel we're
going to dive in with the question of
the day you want to take it yes so
today's question comes from Randy in
Virginia
I'm having my first baby next month and
my parents want to move to my town to
see the baby more often they want to buy
a house but would have to sell theirs at
first to make it happen and our two lazy
to go to apply for a loan oh man I
thought I would just buy them a house
and then they could be my renters I
currently have fifty thousand dollars
left on a 200 don't laugh two hundred
fifty thousand dollar mortgage of my
current home they are in their 70s so if
they bought the home they would pass
they would pay less taxes and claim
homestead would it be smarter for them
to buy the home themselves or is it okay
for me to buy it and make them my
renters this is just the this is just
easiest so they can sell their house and
slowly move into the new one new house
New City stress-free because my dad has
a ton of stuff oh man Randy
okay first and foremost
love the uh
love the heart and the idea that you
want to help your parents uh but no
Randy no you buying a home
uh for them to be your renters not a
good plan and then on top of that you
don't have the money for it I mean you'd
be taking out a second mortgage so
absolutely not
um I think that you can invest in some
plane tickets for them if they want to
come see the baby a few times a year or
they can come just stay at your house
but if they want to move
home their home
full time and live in a new city that
needs to be on their time
yeah they need they're like grown-ups
and stuff
and so they need to do their own deal
besides that dude you never rent to
someone in the second paragraph when in
the first paragraph you called them lazy
so true it's just a basic concept here
as a landlord let me help you with that
okay so if your first description is
lazy and the next description is renter
this is on you so no no they they need
to handle this it's sweet that they want
to come be with a grandbaby I completely
get that if I don't know how great
grandkids are going to be I'd have been
nicer to their parents I completely get
this I understand I agree with the move
so Mom and Dad put their house up for
sale when it sells they can make the
move and buy a house in your city that's
how like normal people do it and stuff
and that's what they need to do so
um and if they get to your city with a
pocket full of money from the sale of
their house and can't find a home right
away they can rent from someone else
please
keep the grandparents
at an arm's length transaction don't let
the grandparents be your renters no it
was just so much that can go wrong with
that and the sad thing is it all will
happen it'll all go wrong hey folks with
debt payments and now with inflation
stealing more and more of your paycheck
we know a lot of you feel like you're
drowning and you're scared to death and
you won't have enough to take care of
your family and oh God it's scary out
there I don't know what I'm going to do
or you're at the point where you say I'm
just so sick of this
if you're ready
if you say I've had it you are ready
we can help you over 10 million people
have been through Financial Peace
University it's our nine lesson course
it'll teach you how to beat debt and
build wealth it's everything you wish
you'd learned about money
because their number one wealth building
tool is your income when you get rid of
your debt you now have control of the
thing that'll make you wealthy
and if you go through Financial Peace
University we will show you how to get
in control how to be on the same page
with your spouse it's a very hard
it's tough
it's a boot camp for money if you want
easy
um you're not going to find something
that works
so the anything that's worth doing you
pay a price to do there's a certain
amount of pain in transformation and
that's what has to occur here Financial
Peace University
ramsesolutions.com FPU check it out
ramsesolutions.com slash FPU Rachel we
can take that family discussion even a
step further and we would do that in
Financial Peace University
and that is don't loan anyone money
particularly family or friends
don't co-sign for people you know don't
you know every time you do these
transactions outside of your particular
household you set yourself up
um the grandmother that called here and
had co-signed for her grandson's pickup
truck it's getting repoed you know and
uh because he had to have a pickup and
his dad wouldn't sign it so the
grandmother did yeah and I think that
you know with this conversation there's
the risk of it going bad which in a lot
of cases it does which causes even more
conflict but even you know I talk to
people like well you know my um uncle Co
signed my car and I paid it off every
month and it's great and I paid it off
and it's fine but even within that even
if mathematically it works relationally
it changes it it's weird it changes the
relationship so from a financial level a
relational level all the way down it's
just not wise it just changes so much
and it's and it's strange it just I mean
and we had I guess it was a call was it
a caller or someone I was talking to and
they had loaned a friend ten thousand
dollars because they needed help
and you know we went back in the
conversation talked about how if you
have the ability just to give it without
strings attached to help someone that's
if that's what you feel called to do
then you do it but the whole idea of
loaning that they're going to pay back
and then the kids showed up uh for a big
dinner that they were all having with
new iPads
and the couple that loaned the money was
like they have two new iPads they owe us
ten thousand dollars and then you start
you start nitpicking every train I mean
it just you can't help it and so again
all the above people not in too much
trouble yeah it's just like your kids
have new iPads you're not in too much I
know I get that yeah so it's just it
changes it changes the relationship and
then if it goes bad and it goes south
then it really can damage relationships
so keeping them separate is it's the
smartest thing or it's a gift right and
you want to make sure that you're not
enabling if there is a gift that is a
blessing and it's helpful generosity is
completely different than a banking
transaction yes yes and when the
borrower slave to the lender and when
you eat
dinner with your father-in-law your
mother-in-law your son-in-law and you
owe them money Thanksgiving dinner
tastes different when you eat with your
master rather than when you eat with
your in-laws
because it oh well they're nice I don't
it's a spiritual principle you cannot
get away from it the law of gravity is
the law of gravity I mean you can have a
nice master and still be a Slave
um I mean that's
hypothetically but I mean you know what
I'm saying I mean that's the it doesn't
have to be harsh it doesn't have to be
out of control it doesn't have to be
rage involved to change the tone right
to change the air in the room it changes
everything so you got to be careful with
this stuff folks and be careful with
this it's not to be mean to somebody
it's actually to be nice no is is a no
will set you free good word powerful
word this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
Cruise number one best-selling author
Ramsey personality and my daughter is my
co-host today here on the Ramsey Show
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five marks in Kansas
City hey Mark welcome to the Ramsay show
thank you both appreciate it I'll get
right to it
okay I've been uh I think what you call
dumb about five years ago five years ago
I co-signed on a mortgage for my ex-wife
and yep she was my ex-wife at the time
fast forward a couple years I've learned
that uh she owes the IRS over 100 Grand
and has since filed a lien on her
property probably in the last year and a
half to two years
so
um somehow she manages a little check to
check and the kids are going to start
falling off from child support and I
don't know how she's going to make it
and what implications it has for me in
this whole scenario
wow
yeah you're right dude you stepped in it
oh man I'm sorry
um
okay first I have to know what possibly
what story could possibly be told to you
to make you co-sign for your ex-wife
because by definition she's X
you're not gonna make me tell you this I
just the three yeah the three kids and
the the violin was playing in the
background I think
maybe caught me at a weak moment
sweet Mark you know I'd heard
yeah you thought you were doing good you
thought you were doing good for you good
for your kids and she's the mother of
your children okay we'll try to cut you
some slack here
I appreciate it we'll still we'll still
put the action in the dumb column I
agree with your opening statement all
right anyway now we're there what do we
do
um no sense in throwing all the
everybody under the bus let's just keep
rolling what what do we do what do we do
what do we do okay she cannot refinance
and get you off because she has an IRS
lien unless you can get the IRS to
subordinate and with it being such a
large lien there's a possibility they
would subordinate she would have to
qualify for the mortgage on her own and
the IRS would have to agree to
subordinate meaning they agree to stay
in second position and put a new
mortgage in front of them instead of the
old one I've gotten them to do that in
negotiations it's rather lengthy but
she's got to qualify and that doesn't
sound like she can
not a chance
now selling the house is very very
difficult
um however uh the first mortgage is how
much
460. what's the house worth
I think at best 850.
when do the kids age out of Child
Support
over the next three years
how much money do you have
uh 1.6
half of that's in retirement
okay
um
when I do something stupid and it costs
me money
I call it stupid tax
uh well I've heard this before
so I think you're getting ready to write
a stupid text check at some point in
this equation now sooner rather than
later later rather than sooner depending
on when the kids age out and all that
kind of stuff but let's pretend they
aged out and there's no more need for
you to have violins in the background uh
in terms of her having this house I
would walk over and say I will give you
ten thousand dollars
if you'll sell your house
and then she sells the house she has
enough equity to pay off the IRS and she
gets she gets rid of the mortgage that
has you on it and then she goes and gets
her another house with the equity and
she's better than me too that's great
she gets rid of you you get rid of her
this was the original intent of the
whole thing until you stepped in it
um yeah and you wouldn't push her to
sell the house now because well I mean
she could but I think it's going to be a
harder sale and plus you for her to do
that you did this partly to give your
kids a better place to live and they're
not aged out yet right
that's correct so I mean if you do it
today you're putting the kids in the
street too
correct but she could make the move
today I don't know what mindset she's in
but I'll tell you what she's probably
got she got an IRS breathing down her
neck she's got a house that she's
wondering how she's going to be able to
afford when child support drops off
she's worried about this stuff deep down
not on top of not on top like you are
but even she feels it in the tenseness
across her shoulder blades because she's
human we all can see the truck coming
towards our car right
yes and so she sees that and she does
not know how to get out have y'all had
any conversations about it Mark you and
her
very little
in the greatest communicators that
probably surprises her but no but not
very much okay okay well part of that is
yeah she's she's buried under stress and
it's got It's got part of your name on
it yeah
so you know I would just sit down if you
can have a conversation if it's possible
and just say hey here's an idea and I'll
help you one last time if you sell the
house you get rid of me and the IRS and
you've got enough equity to go get you
another house
you can either do that now or you can do
it later and I'll write a check to help
you do this
because it gets me off the mortgage
because it's worth 10 grand or 20 grand
if you got 1.6 to get rid of this
contingent liability this cosigned
liability because if this thing goes
belly up she's going to get foreclosed
on and you're going to get to ride with
her because you can't stop the
Foreclosure because you can't you can't
force the sale of the house the only
good news in this whole story is the
house has enough equity to take out the
IRS
it needs to be sold for her sake yeah
and it blesses you in the process
that's right so let's dangle some kind
of a carrot that causes that to happen
now or when the kids age out I don't
care which but
sooner the better because I got a
feeling this is
it'll be a relief to her if she
understands whether she is conscious of
it or not she's carrying a load of
stress oh yeah and Dr John deloney talks
about that when we're in debt the this
lack of agency this lack of autonomy
because we're a slave that that she's
carrying the weight of that when she's I
mean he said and she's living paycheck
to paycheck anyways yeah well and then
you have a lien on the house from the
IRA I mean the last thing you want on
your life on your list of things to do
is to deal with the KGB I mean the IRS
it's just they are not this is not a
creditor you want to have okay no the
penalties the interest it's just out of
control their power is virtually
unlimited uh in this case I've seen a
few times not often that they'll
actually come in and force the sale of
the house to get their money to get the
money um and if she doesn't do something
with this lean eventually they'll get
around to that now they're not exactly
efficient but eventually they'll get
around to it so but the stress of this
is just on everybody so here's an
interesting thing now now you know we we
poked at Mark a little bit we also gave
him a little bit of a break and you know
we kind of laughed with him and at him
both in his presence so it's all okay
right but the uh because we've all done
stupid stuff but the the thing is this
there's a couple of things here that you
can take away as a money principle
sometimes
doing what it feels like is
you're you're trying to help someone but
you're doing it in such an illegitimate
way you end up actually hurting the
person you're trying to help
co-signing does that every time
there's actually a proverb in the Bible
that says only a fool co-signs for
another the Contemporary English version
says if you co-sign for someone else
you're stupid
it's in the Bible okay so I mean and so
co-signing is an illegitimate way to
help someone meaning if you don't have
the money for junior to get a car and
you co-sign for junior to get a car you
are stepping in it for sure when it's
your ex-wife you're stepping in it up to
your knees you need boots for this walk
unbelievable man you know for sure and
sometimes when you give someone some
money even without a debt or without a
co-signing involved uh what and and it's
enabling the buy something they can't
afford the behavior right right then
you've the you know my well my my
daughter needed a house and I gave her
the down payment and now she's got a
house payment that she can't afford how
many times does that happen like every
week on the show a well-meaning parent
so you got to be careful what you're
participating in because enablers are
the nicest people in the world they're
sweet people
that don't know how to say no and then
they enable bad behavior and so while
you are trying to be a help you end up
being a curse in their life with money
you had dollar signs on it too curse
with dollar signs yeah and mark That's
not aimed at you that's just aimed at
all the things all of us have done like
what you did this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five in the lobby
of Ramsey Solutions on the debt free
stage Tim is with us hey Tim how are you
hi Dave this is awesome thank you so
much well it's an honor to have you sir
where do you live I live in Cameron Park
California about 30 minutes east of
Sacramento very cool well welcome to
Nashville and how much data have you
paid off sir
180 500 way to go and how long did this
take you seven years three months very
good and your range of income during
that seven years my take-home pay was
forty eight thousand to sixty eight
thousand dollars cool what do you do for
a living I work at a house Hazardous
Waste Facility basically we take
household panes cleaners paints that
kind of stuff
um that's kind of what I do I do it for
a local government agency down there
yeah cool okay good what kind of debt
was your
181 thousand all mortgage you paid off
looking at weird people I paid for house
zero debt in the entire world totally
free way to go man seven years you did
that yeah man and in California yeah
most people California are like this is
impossible really what's this house
worth about three three and a quarter ah
way to go man how's it feel to not have
a payment in the world Dave I did it in
in August and you know it's so freeing
you know you don't owe anybody anything
I mean last month my washer broke I'm
like oh look I'm gonna go buy a new
washer let's be fun to do why not so
it's like little things you like I can
do there's freedom and not having owe
anybody money just amazing yeah I love
the T-shirt Ramen Ramsay approved meal
every night good old ramen noodles right
yeah I just thought I'd have a little
fun with it yeah well done well done
okay what started you on this journey
seven years ago doing this Ramsey stuff
well my story my story started about 15
years ago I mean I had the old
my about 15 years ago I had what was
known as house fever and what happened
for me is is that I wanted a house fast
fast fast fast and so I didn't just do a
30-year loan I did a 35-year loan with a
with first five years being interest
only and that was dumb wow
but you know and it was amazing because
right then I switched to a new job and I
didn't realize that I didn't really own
the house the house owned me because I
my my paycheck was only twenty four
hundred dollars a month and between my
eight
between my mortgage and my HOA was
seventeen hundred dollars and it was
tough
what was the wake-up call
um you know I took your class in 09 and
I was so grateful but you know back in
0809 the mortgage is tanked and I just
couldn't refinance and I'm just like
what am I going to do about this so I
prayed about it and I'm like you know
what this is what I'm gonna do I'm just
gonna a lot of people in my
neighborhoods were just walking away
from their houses I said you know what I
signed up for this deal I'm Gonna Keep
with it but I just wish I could get it
refinanced
so when finally in 2015
I looked back at refinancing was able to
refinance to a decent loan and said
thank you God I was able to get out of
that and so once I did I said okay this
game on now
um I said I'm gonna put everything I got
on this darn thing excuse my language
but and so basically at that time my
average between the last seven years has
been about four thousand dollars I was
putting about twenty five hundred
dollars of that on the mortgage yeah but
you want it out I I want it done I just
no more
and for seven years you just kept
chipping away yeah every every every
month every month what was the hardest
part for you oh the hardest part I say
for me was just
The Daily Grind yeah of just keeping to
the budget writing it down I mean I had
this big old huge poster board that's
like that big that I looked at every
time I went to sleep and it's I don't
know if you see it on the screen but it
shows I mean 180 000 it's not for me it
wasn't a it was a lot of money for me so
but you did it yeah and it was worth it
it was worth it oh it's so much more
freeing now yeah so I have a freedom and
it's just amazing how that feels great
job Tim thank you so much well you're
gonna be able to do a lot now that you
don't have any payments what's your
first big thing you're gonna do with
money now that you don't have any
payments well I paid it off last August
so I went to Australia with my brother
that was fun I got there you go that was
a lot of fun paid for perfectly in cash
and so I took care of that that was
wonderful and then I did this and so
it's just the freedom that you have of
making choices
and that's just you don't owe anybody
any money it's just amazing I didn't
realize it until I was out how amazing
that is well it's it's easy to think
about what it'll be like but you your
body really even feels different when
you're completely free it's it's hard to
tell people until they're there yeah one
last thing I like to mention one thing I
learned through this experience is that
for me I found that the interest you pay
on a debt is price you pay for your own
inpatience there's a cost to wanting
something right now
and for me that costs a lot of my money
because I wasn't willing to wait and so
for those who are listening
be patient
the less money you the less money you
give to the bank is more money for you
and that's just the simple truth that's
right it's a simple formula but it works
yeah it really is yeah proud of you man
thank you sir you were your biggest
cheerleaders out well I had um my mom
was really a very appreciative of of big
cheerleader for me and
you know I had the um Facebook Ramsay
group that I listened to all the time to
give me encouragement and that was so
wonderful that was a great group yeah it
was a baby steps group yeah yeah
Facebook it was just a wonderful group
always positive always encouraging and
so that was always wonderful very cool
well good for you brother
congratulations done man thank you well
done if somebody's listening and maybe
this is the first time they ever heard
of this idea what do you tell them the
secret to getting out of debt is
the secret for me was writing it plain
writing on paper to pen and writing it
visual I you know as I said I had that
big poster board that was very visceral
to me and I had to make it
a hard thing not just a money thing and
so once I did that it was just a matter
of time not what if it's going to happen
when it's going to happen what's
interesting is is that not only are you
debt free but you've transformed yeah
and if you're a different person because
of the process yeah it's it's been so
amazing and the people here have been so
wonderful to me it's been awesome good
well we love having folks visit us here
in the lobby particularly to do a debt
free scream baby
everything yeah so we've got the uh live
and give bundle for you The Total Money
Makeover book The Baby Steps millionaire
book both number one best sellers and of
course the Financial Peace University
membership if you've done or have read
any of those those are yours to give
away as well so live and give enjoy them
or give them or however you want to
however you want to enjoy them that's
they're there for you to say thank you
for coming out here and we're very very
proud of you well thank you sir thank
you so much for this very very well done
all right Tim from Sacramento 180 31
thousand dollars paid off in seven years
and three months making forty eight to
sixty eight house in California is paid
off
shut up I love it count it down Tim
let's hear a debt free Scream one two
three
that's how you do it Tim yeah
I'm free so it sounds like when you get
free ah when you get the chains off
that's what it sounds like Pretty
stinking incredible
it's amazing absolutely amazing
and I love it just and he said it was
like it's it's the grind it's the
everyday choices that you make sure day
and that's long and the culture in a
culture they can't stay with something
for seven minutes without picking up
their phone and doom scrolling Instagram
oh you stay with some of the Seven Years
Years consistently yep seven years
pushing through pushing through pushing
through pushing through and that's
dedication I mean because I do hear
people talk about that free screens I'll
see some haters online like well those
people they're making half a million
dollars a year and all of a sudden I'm
like no no they're not I mean it is like
48 48 to 68 and I'm like and it's just
that diligence day in and day out and
it's proof that anyone can Tim is that
example anyone who believes that that it
is possible and that they can work a
plan they can do it and Tim he's that
he's that example it's amazing I read
that Tortoise and the hair book a bunch
of times every time I read it the
tortoise wins this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
thank you for joining us America this is
the Ramsey Show common sense for your
dollars and cents and for your life
Rachel Cruz number one best-selling
author of Ramsay personalities my
co-host today Marquita is with us in
Seattle hey Marquita welcome to the
Ramsay show
hi Dave hi Rachel thank you for taking
my call and I need some help I need
assistance I need guidance with how to
set up an estate plan as an estate
planning for my on behalf of my mom
diagnosed with ALS
um period of the numbers thank you Dave
um it's it's a lot it's a it's a huge
bird in Industry how old how old is she
my mom is turning 73 this month in
February oh I'm so sorry
okay thank you oh man she owns a home
it's her primary home
um the value is between the land in the
house is between 500 000 to 750 000. her
income of pension and social security is
about uh 33 000 or 3 500 per month
her mortgage she owes she has about she
owes one 139 000
uh on her mortgage she has 33 000 she
owes and
33.5 in credit card debt she has a car
that she's leasing which has a balance
of twenty three thousand twenty three
twenty three four five
and her total debt is 196
599 including our mortgage including the
credit cards including the lease
yes sir okay and her plan
um is to keep the house and sell it uh
keep it in the family
and I was wondering why how would we go
about
why would you keep the house in the
family
uh those are her wishes
I know but why
why does it matter
is the house is the house family
property or is it just her house it's
family property yes it's been in the
family generationally
uh no since her since she since I was
born into the house so since she was
married okay
well our medical bills are expected to
be about 250 000 for ALS Clinic
um and we're wondering about what what's
the best way to go about this yeah
um because her wishes are is that she
would like to
keep the house and give it to one of the
kids yeah
I'm so sorry so it's myself and two
brothers
yeah well when you pass away
what you own
stands good for what you owe
okay
so if the family wanted to keep the
house
uh they would have a hundred and forty
thousand dollar mortgage on the house
still
um they can pay that mortgage and keep
the house but the clinic bills the
credit card and the car will all have to
be paid
right so by asking you all to keep the
house she's asking you to take on the
clinic bills the car bill and the credit
card bill
because there's no cash around to pay
those things correct
well if I was to well as of now I've
been I've moved into a sister
um and if I was to absorb the mortgage
payment and the pro and the annual
property taxes and her income can absorb
the credit card debt and and pay that
off
um in 10 months
and then you've got a car that you got
to deal with and then you got 250 000 in
ALS Clinic bills to deal with
right am I missing something
no those are the numbers yeah and those
are the facts
so you have a harsh
uh diagnosis
and a harsh reality that you're going to
be walking through in the next
whatever 12 to 36 months
and um
uh and and I don't want to be the person
that adds another harsh reality to your
situation but the house will be sold
well because you can't pay the height
you can't pay the bills
and so the equity in the home will pay
the bills
I'm sorry
because you listen if you don't pay the
clinic
they're going to sue the estate and take
a lien on the house and force the sale
of the house
and you don't have 250 000 and she
doesn't either and I guess neither of
your brothers do do they
have my brother purchased a home uh last
year so as of now no no even if one of
you is sitting on a 250 000 cash balance
in your personal checking account I
would not suggest you use it to keep
this house
I'm sorry I mean it's um the house is
there and we can use it for her final
days
and make her comfortable
and there's nothing to keep you from
doing that that that works fine and
obviously the more of the credit card
debt and the in the car you can clean up
during that time with her income and you
take care of the mortgage that's all
fine your brothers need to be aware that
you're going to be reimbursed for you
paying the mortgage bill
upon her death out of the proceeds or
the sale of the house before they get
any inheritance
but basically there is enough to give
you all some inheritance after
everything's paid
uh but not much
right because her net her net worth is
her net worth even at a 250 000 medical
bill to it is approaching zero
got it
so what sort of trust or a estate
planning would you recommend
uh just a will
because there's no you can't hide these
things in a trust and keep this from
happening okay so just need a good will
uh you need to go see an estate planning
attorney and they can help you draft a
will that gives these instructions but
and I don't know how to break this to
your mom I don't know how to be kind to
her with the uh you know especially in
this setting but
um
I I I've never
participated in things where we didn't
tell that everybody the whole truth that
it turned out well
and so I mean you could just choose to
not tell her
and just drop a will that says uh that
you guys get the house but the answer is
when it actually goes to Probate Court
you're going to find out you can't keep
the house
no matter what the will says
because the will does not have the power
to do away with all these debts you
follow me
yes and so you still end up with the
equation what you own minus what you owe
your net worth is how it works now you
guys don't inherit the debt let's
pretend that the uh if the medical bills
are a million dollars
then they're just not going to get paid
because there's not enough money in her
estate to pay them and you guys do not
inherit debt
that's good news but you don't inherit
assets without paying all the bills
associated with the estate
that makes sense
I'm so sorry oh it's so hard and I don't
want to be the guy telling you all this
stuff but that gets to be my job today I
guess
right well we'll pray for you darling so
a revocable a living trust would not
work either it won't cause this to go
away
it just is another way to facilitate the
exact same answer
oh okay yeah that you can't hide Assets
in a trust from debt
you can hide them from people and keep
people's hands off of them but uh and
you know it's a little bit strong a
little bit more way of a strong arm to
ensure an estate wishes go the way you
want because it's in trust and you can't
you can't it's harder to break a trust
than it is a will but um but neither one
of them are that easy to break actually
assuming they're drawn up properly but
but still at the end of the day the
creditors get paid there's not an estate
planning tool a living trust and a
revocable trust is not an estate
planning tool that makes debt go away
makes sense for the results of the debt
and the results of the debt is the
person that is owed can collect their
money as long as there's something to
collect against
so if the house were in the trust the
equity in the house it goes to the
beneficial interest of an individual
uh however the trust and the beneficial
interest can be sued because it's part
of the estate so I'm not an attorney you
probably you do you do need to sit down
with one and you need to spend a little
bit of money getting a proper wheel
drawn up to make sure I'm not right
but I'm afraid you're going to find out
I'm right
sorry wow
oh my goodness this puts this hour of
the Ramsay show in the books
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the pots
moving in storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love
and create actual amazing relationships
Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality number
one best-selling author my daughter is
my co-host today the phone number here
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five Kennedy is with us in
Indianapolis to start off this
particular hour hi Kennedy how are you
better than we deserve what's up
because
um I have a son he's four and a half and
his dad and I are no long together but
I'm in a great marriage now and we are
actually on being step two we're working
steps and my son's dad he's not very
good with money you know we built a
house together I wasn't on it obviously
but we built a house together and he
picked out everything that was super
expensive he went and he bought a brand
new Jeep when he had kind of a beater he
lives to like impress people and he's
not a bad dad we're on good terms but
he's just really bad with money and I'm
trying to work with my son now on chores
and saving money and making money and
I'm worried that his dad is going to
show him habits like going out to eat
all the time and buying every single
thing and it's just kind of going to
reverse what I do here at home can you
help with that
yeah I mean this is this can be a tough
one the good news is though Kennedy I
mean your son's five which is great
right I mean they're young and yes
impressionable but but you can start
doing things with him
um that's not going to completely
unravel just because he sees his dad and
I think
parents and I have to even realize this
even with my kids so much of what they
learn is what they're watching and so
more is caught than taught and you only
have the power to control what goes on
in your house you don't have the power
to control what's going to be going on
in your husband's house and so I think
the older he gets the more conversations
you guys can have around money but right
now where you're at the fact that he's
five I think instilling these small
habits and again Kennedy I we have a
five-year-old at home we do this stuff I
teach it every day and we still probably
aren't as intentional as we should be
with our kids right so like there's a
lot of Grace in this it's okay
um they're still young but I think you
know slowly but surely that consistency
over time of what he's going to see from
you that's what you can control and so
that's what I would focus my energy on
um and again I'm sure as he gets older
there's going to be more questions and I
think you have those conversations with
respect for his dad and still honoring
him but also telling the truth of hey
here's what comments sense looks like
when it comes to money here's how to
hear our habits to have to set you up to
win right because I think it was Meg
Meeker that said we don't raise kids
just to be good kids we raise them to be
good adults and so yes I love Meg maker
yeah it's kind of having that long-term
mindset uh is helpful too but um you
know Meg would tell you first and
foremost never trash is dead to him
um
but then sometimes the way I can find my
answer on some of these things is if I
take it to an extreme it tells me how to
handle it let's take it let's take a
different thing instead of money let's
just make up something kind of weird or
wild to see how we would handle that
let's say his dad drops the F-bomb every
other word
he does actually oh who knew and um and
we don't do that at our house okay we
don't okay so how do we handle that well
we don't trash dad
and we can't control what Dad does with
his mouth over at the other place but we
can only control it when you're with me
and in this house we don't speak that
way
we have more class than that
we're not trash
okay uh you know we have we have a sense
of decorum we have a sense of nobility
in our home and we don't we don't speak
using those types of words uh they're
called vulgar we don't teach a
four-year-old that but I mean this is
what's going through your mind right and
so you go well I can't control that but
all I can control is what we do here and
and so your interaction with him is we
don't do that when you're here
okay and uh you know we don't do that
here and so we don't when we're here we
work and we do our chores when we're
here we're generous with our money when
we're here we save our money when we're
here we make wise purchase decisions
with our money as coached by our mom I
and then that's all you can do now what
will happen at the end of the story is
this okay common sense and love and
proper truth does win out in these
things but it takes time so when he's 26
and he did something stupid with money
he's going to know what stupid looks
like because it was described to him by
you
and so he's going to go gosh I really
can't model my life after my dad my
mom's plot process works I need to
gravitate back to that and I'm going to
probably go to my mom yeah and if I need
it if I need help if I need financial
advice I don't go to my dad who's broke
I'm gonna go to my mom who taught me
this stuff the whole time growing up and
but that he'll go through the phase like
all kids do we're first you're you you
know somewhere around 14 years old my
mama is stupid gland kicks in right and
then it takes until about 30 or 25 or
whatever for it to grow back right
before and then suddenly at some point
in their 20s or whatever you're a genius
again and you're going to go through
that regardless of whether you're
together or whether you're apart so uh
uh you know that's gonna happen here
it's not going to be a perfect path and
there's not anything you can do to
protect him from
uh bad money habits or vulgar mouths
when they exist with your ex because the
truth is too Kennedy you know you could
you could have been in a marriage
raising him and doing everything
possible to teach them new wives with
money and then at the end of the day
when they go off on their own suddenly
they're adults that have to make their
own decisions too and you know we're
getting even that second generation of
Ramsey it's like that that kids that
grew up listening to Dave on the show
make very sure you talk about what you
and your current husband are doing to
the four-year-old in age-appropriate
ways so they see the model
and you coach him on his personal
Behavior so he sees the model and then
it'll work out it's going to be okay but
there's no Ironclad protection when
you've got
you know when he's going to get exposed
to the virus on the other side
you know it's just like the mouth thing
it's the same thing and so you're get
you just got a bad model over there and
that that's that's you know and but you
can't fix your ex-husband that's why
he's your ex
so and you can't control him that's why
you're he's your ex but even with
parents too what I was saying earlier
was you know even if you do
and about any any area of parenting
right you oh there's no guarantee yeah
right so all you can do is give it your
best shot that's right so that's what I
would say too Kennedy is like give
yourself some Grace yeah do what you can
in your household and then at the end of
the day launching them into the world
it's like okay if you model it More's
caught then taught and you teach it
you've done all you can do that's your
best shot and it works out more times
than not so that's why we do it that's
why we do it hang on we're going to send
you a copy of smart money smart kids
that Rachel and I did together teaching
your children how to be smart with money
so that when they grow up they have a
brain and what's hard in those
situations is like the Disney dad thing
too when they go to dance when they go
to Mom or Dad's house that's the spender
and it's like oh we're gonna have all
this fun into a kid it's like oh this is
way more fun and that's a hard pill to
swallow too when you're the parents like
I've only grown up in this equation I
know it's hard we're doing great Kennedy
yeah yeah you're gonna it's gonna work
out hang on Austin's gonna pick up we'll
send you a copy of smart money smart
kids it was the first number one
bestseller Rachel had and the first one
I've and the only book I've ever done
with her that was a number one because
it's the only book we ever did together
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
thank you
thank you for joining us America hey
tickets are going fast for our Building
Wealth live tour we have four more stops
on the Live Events a three to eight
thousand of you gonna be at each of one
of these thank you you don't want to
miss these they're going to be a blast
if you're doing this stuff it's kind of
like a big pep rally to come around all
the Ramsey people doing this stuff it's
a lot of fun and we're going to talk
about how to build wealth in the middle
of all this craziness going on in 2023
February 16th just a couple of weeks
Rachel Cruz George Campbell Jade warshaw
and I will be in Indianapolis few
tickets left to Indy it's not quite sold
out I'm a little surprised by February
16th it'll be there though where it's
just around the corner the next week
will be in Austin Texas again a few
tickets left Ken Coleman Dr John deloney
Jade warshaw and me and April 24th uh
Rachel Cruz and I and George Campbell
and Christina Ellis will be in Salt Lake
City I'll be along with Ken Coleman Dr
John deloney and Christina Ellis on the
final stop of the tour in Anaheim on May
2nd tickets are 49 you can get a four
pack and bring your friends for only 175
you pay more than 175 to go to a concert
of almost any kind and this will
actually give you the information to
change your life now concerts are fun
this will be fun but you also will come
away motivated and going oh man all this
junk I'm hearing on the news I think I
can still win anyway
ramsesolutions.com events get your
tickets right now the Building Wealth
live tour Indianapolis
Austin Salt Lake City Anaheim
looking forward to seeing you guys come
on out now the phone again
ramseysolutions.com
events all right let's go to Julie and
Saint Paul Minnesota hi Julie welcome to
the Ramsay show
hi thanks for taking my call sure
um I've had recently my husband and I
have had some changes um with work and
what I'm trying to figure out is how to
make
um monthly contributions that we both
make to a joint household account
Equitable and fair
um he's recently accepted a new job
making considerably more money
um and I'm straight commission so my
money is always variable
it'd be different if you know we had he
made a hundred thousand imh 50 then it's
pretty easy how to figure out but how do
you figure something out when somebody's
variable commission every month how long
have you guys been married
we've been married about three years
we've been together about eight and
sharing finances for about six okay well
my answer is really simple Julie it's
all of yours together
so once it hits a bank account that you
guys share regardless of who brings in
the money it is your money you guys
together as a couple
it is your both of your money both of
your monies all of your monies together
so
um you're you're acting you're you're
acting like you're still roommates
you're not roommates your husband and
wife
and so there's a there's a power teacher
said and now you are one he did not
pronounce you a joint venture
there is okay there is power and Power
in combining finances combining checking
accounts working out of the same pot
regardless of who brings in the money
that together you're a team and and even
studies recently there's been like two
or three recently coming out talking
about even the satisfaction the marriage
satisfaction and joy is higher with
couples that see themselves as one when
it comes to money and it is it's
probably one of the more
counter-cultural things I feel like we
talk a lot about countercultural stuff
on the show but for so many people they
do what you guys do they're running
these kind of these two separate Lanes
trying to figure out okay who pays what
Bill what's fair what's equal
when you just scrap all of that and say
hey this is our house when our incomes
come in it is our income what are we
going to do with our money and you see
yourself as a team as one as Unified
and and my thing is I'm like if you can
share a bed
you can share a bank account you guys
are married you are one you are together
now in your budget you have a line item
that's a Julie line item and you have
money to go and spend and enjoy and
that's great you know I have a Rachel
line item
and I can go buy a sweaters and new pair
of jeans and I'm not having to like text
him every time right we have a certain
amount of money that I get to spend
every month a certain amount of money he
spends so there's still a level of yeah
you still you have money to spend but
that's agreed upon that amount together
and so something changes Julie I'm
telling you you both have power not just
tactically things change when you
combine accounts but emotionally the
unity that's created you start to see
yourselves as one and you win faster
financially when you do that you work
together you communicate there's so
there's so many Pros I'm telling you so
many Pros that come out so much data to
back this up by the way of working
together it's it it sounds devastatingly
old-fashioned though doesn't it
very independent
the majority equally too you know but
that always sometimes the problem is
when you're doing it your way it almost
feels like if you're not putting in more
your vote doesn't count as much
and it does you have equal votes in the
marriage and equal votes on whether we
buy a house equal votes on whatever's if
you don't believe me visit divorce court
they'll give both of you an equal vote
right the law says that exactly the law
says that so here's an interesting
extreme okay my wife Sharon left the
workplace uh of her own choice uh when
my oldest daughter Rachel's older sister
was born and Denise is what 30 something
years old right so for 30 something
years Sharon has not had an income
and yet Sharon has a great income
because we
have a great income
we own a house now we do at our house
still say that's your car because it's
the one she drives more than me and it's
the one with the dent from hitting the
garage door but I said that out loud but
yeah that's your car this is my car but
they're our cars it's our vacation it's
our retirement it's our money and we are
going to design a life we want to live
together we both have a vote she has the
same vote I have and she brings nothing
of income to the equation
I didn't say she brought nothing to the
equation I said she brought nothing of
income to the equation let's be very
very clear about that after the garage
door joke but um I'm already in deep
kimchi here but the uh but that that's
the uh uh that's the thing so yeah I I
think
um
I I think that uh uh I think you can try
this
as an experiment because there's nothing
that says you can't undo our suggestion
try it for six months Julie between now
and summer
change your language
when you do
our
not yours and mine our
our and see if you don't notice some
subtle shifts with that communication in
your relationship
I it's it's proven and it's just we've
been doing this a long time and we
Rachel's right we get trashed on social
media for this because it's like it's so
it's it's like old-fashioned see the old
marriage vows you know uh for richer for
poorer we've all heard that in sickness
and health we all heard that the old
book of common prayer marriage vows say
unto thee all my worldly Goods I pledge
that's you don't hear that in a weren't
marriage anymore either no but and you
know 50 years ago almost every wedding
you went to you would have heard that
okay and our 60 years ago
um I've been married 40 and it wasn't in
mine but um
but yeah I mean that's it's old school
is what I'm saying it's kind of it's got
a very uh uh almost a Victorian feel to
it now and what can come with that is
the sense that you've lost power and
we're not suggesting that your vote is
diminished no I'll guarant dad blame to
you to you my uh hillbilly wife has a
vote okay she takes her I'll call you a
hillbilly can you call her a hillbilly
she's hillbilly too we're both noble
noble Hillbillies but uh but I mean the
chances of me taking away your mother's
vote is zero right oh my God even if I
wanted to be overbearing it's not an
option okay yeah that 100 100 and I will
say this one of the pushbacks I get on
social media is well we just kept
fighting all the time and now we have
separate accounts and we don't fight
anymore it's because you're just denial
that's okay so that's my point is I'm
like that's the exact fight you need to
be having to have a deep rich marriage
like you can't just sweep things into
the rug and function like two different
you know two different places and then
call that okay that's not okay I woke up
and didn't admit it it changed it forces
you to communicate and and work together
as a team and I'm telling you Julie it's
worth it it changes in your marriage
that's our pitch give it a shot this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money
um some of you are new to this and we've
got literally millions of you joining us
in the last couple of months thank you
we're so glad you're here and we want
the opportunity to love you an
opportunity to help you
um and and sometimes you get in here and
you you hear information that's new to
you it's a new way of thinking and uh
for some folks in our culture today that
that's not a challenge because they're
looking for new information they're
looking for a new way of looking at
things other times it's a challenge for
you because you get all Disturbed and
you think it becomes your job then to uh
get us to change
um you got confused about how this
relationship works
okay because this is called the Ramsey
show this is what the this this is who
we are and what we teach if you want to
do a show go do a show okay but get some
hate at the break uh no I just I always
get hate I've gotten hate for 30 years
you're gonna get a hate after that last
call like you know you always get haters
to bring this whole thing up you get
trashed on this stuff and uh but that
the whole point is let me help you with
this I for 30 years every letter that
has come to Ramsey
to me has been answered
except junk mail and hate mail
there's no reason to answer hate mail
and there's no reason to answer idiots
in the comments section of YouTube
okay there's no reason because let me
just did you think we were going to
change because of you little troll
you got confused how this works we're
not going to change because we're right
so you that's why you came here in the
first place because you wanted new
information because the information you
were using sucked and so did your life
and so we're here to help you with that
it's what we do and and so but don't get
confused
how about this stuff it's it's just
hilarious to me that I was just reading
but there are things you learn in life I
learned I learned on the air or
something yesterday okay and I would
love to hear it and so I don't mind
learning but but I didn't learn it from
a troll
sure okay and I didn't and so and I
didn't learn it from an activist oh give
me a break get a job
um so so just you know I was just
thinking about how much crap you're
gonna catch
you actually see it but I don't even see
it because I don't even look if you read
comments after an article you understand
why some species kill their young I mean
it's just un the the ignorance that
abounds out there is unbelievable so uh
the interesting thing about this uh you
know the last 25 or 30 years we've all
grown up uh some of you have grown up
with and I've adapted as an old fart to
walking around with this magic wand in
my hand
and so I can push a button and stuff
shows up on my front porch
I'm magic
and so I must matter
I've got great power
no you really don't do you think that's
where it comes from yeah oh I guarantee
you we gave people agency beyond their
ability to control it we gave them
autonomy beyond their ability to control
it and thus they become trolls because
someone they thought they got confused
and thought someone cared what they
thought Hey listen you live in your
mother's basement I don't care what you
think
it's not I'm sorry
you haven't earned the right to speak
into this yet okay so that's that just
to go ahead and help you guys that are
new how this stuff works well you're
arrogant no I'm just confident there's a
difference
arrogance is unfounded
okay we've been doing this 30 freaking
years and the prince yes and it works
and the principles work and they're
they're biblically based common sense
when things used to not be so nutty out
there and this agency and autonomy we've
given to people who have to have an
opinion and to speak in and to raise
hell with people uh when they haven't
earned the right to do it uh is not good
for our culture
it's damaging our culture because then
people are actually being swayed by
crazy people
the mob and so it's hard to cancel us we
own this and we're not going to stop
so if you don't like it your only option
is leave
because we don't even care if you
it doesn't bother us so just kind of
helping you guys sit out while the
others work so I just got to every so
often we have to reset reset the
equation here man you drop the b word
Dave so I mean it's it's okay Life's
good Life's good it is and listen
it's fine see I it's so fun I'm like
just it's just different personalities
if ever if there are people that
totally disagree and they think we're
nuts I'm like that's great I don't
that's fine you can think we're nuts ah
just go somewhere else I mean it didn't
but it didn't why are you wasting your
breath that's my point yeah Move Along
little doggy yeah so there we go we can
handle the Lawson ratings I promise you
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Jason's with us
in Kansas City hi Jason how are you
you doing great yourself better than I
deserve man what's up have you ever
trolled someone Jason on the internet
Dave needs to know right now Jason I
have never trolled anybody I haven't I'm
just kidding other than I mean I get
patrolling is when you don't own it but
I I've I've given smart alec answers
back when Twitter used to work back
before it deteriorated into a cesspool
but um but anyway Jason we brought you
in Jason you got you walked right into
the bandsaw how can we help man I did
apparently so uh it may be an easy
answer for you so I was one wanting to
refinance my home for for against some
Equity to pay off some bills and
expenses that I have and maybe also do a
little bit of renovating in my home
and not sure as far as if it would be
the investigation area to do that or
to eliminate some bills and that would
eliminate most of what I have and then I
just have a little bit of a higher
mortgage payment yeah
um the problem with that process is is
that we've not seen it to work because
you didn't really eliminate the bills
you just moved them
yeah I can't visualize that and when it
comes to renovating your home you just
borrowed money to go renovate your home
and so we want to teach we want to lead
you if we can out of debt not into debt
and out of debt so that you can have
money to invest so that you can be
wealthy and outrageously generous and
have an awesome life that's where we
want to lead you so we're based on that
we're going to work the debt snowball on
the bills and then save up and pay cash
for the renovations how expensive
renovation you want to do
uh really I just want to um do the
kitchen which I'm gonna do personally
myself so I'm not paying somewhere to do
it it's not going to be a lot of money
how much debt do you have Jason
um
in total maybe about 15 000. okay how
much do you make a year
uh I'm a little over 50. okay yeah so I
would just pay off that 15 and then get
a good emergency fund do you have any
savings
I do I have it's about three thousand
about three okay yeah so I would take
that I would take two of that throw it
at the 15 keep working that get a great
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses
and then at that point if you want to
start some retirement saving on the side
for the for the remodel of the house I
think that's great because here here's a
big problem Jason that we find and this
is if people do something like this or
even if they get a big inheritance or
like a big end of the year bonus and
they have a pile of money that they're
going to throw and pay off debt what we
have found is personal finance is 80
Behavior it's only 20 head knowledge so
it's almost like you're putting a
Band-Aid on your past money habits just
to clear it and again just like Dave
said you're reshuffling it you're still
you still have that debt uh it just goes
into it goes into the house instead and
there's something about you Jason that
that is transformed when you work the
process and you pay the debt off you
save the cash and you do it and in that
process that's when your habits start to
change in your Outlook versus just
moving debt out of the house throwing it
fixing that problem over here the 15 000
you know doing it all so working the
actual will plan is where you're going
to see long-term results not just with
your money but with you hey man we'll
help you we want you to go through
Financial Peace University as our guest
I'll pay for it okay hang on we'll have
Austin pick up and we'll get you in the
class you and your wife go through that
class and this will make more sense to
you because if you just snap your
fingers and the debt goes away and you
don't change your habits the debt grows
back that's Rachel's point and that's
what we don't want to see you have
happen here so hang on we'll walk with
you and show you how to do this
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
our scripture of the day First
Corinthians 3 12 and 13. if anyone
Builds on the foundation with gold
silver costly Stones wood hay or straw
each one's work will become obvious
for the day we'll disclose it because it
will be revealed by fire the fire will
test the quality of each one's work
Alex Honnold said no matter the risks we
take we always consider the end to be
too soon even though in life more than
anything else the quality should be more
important than the quantity
JT is with us in Tupelo Mississippi hi
JT welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey Mr
Mr it's Rachel better than we deserve
sir how can we help
um yes so my wife and I we are actually
in the process of a new chapter in our
lives uh several years ago we went in
and throughout Mexico and Brazil doing
Mission work and spreading the Gospel of
Jesus Christ into the streets and we
fell in love with helping people it was
something that um absolutely changed and
shaped our lives in the biggest way
possible and God really put on our
hearts to
do this permanently so upon arriving
back to the United States we set out and
um pretty much turned a school bus into
a home and um so we're going to be
taking this bus in and throughout Latin
and South America and um our goal or
really our mindset is to be doing this
very long term possibly 10 years even
20. I don't really know
um but
previously
the way we did it was we would just
raise money quit our jobs leave
do all these things in the streets and
then come back find new jobs and then
repeat the process but doing it this way
uh we're not really going to do that we
want to permanently be there and so my
question is in regards to this we're
we're looking at somewhere around forty
thousand dollars more or less a year and
that's not a lot a lot but I think it's
more than enough that we will need to do
it and
um we're trying to figure out
which direction to take for the amount
of for the the support that's coming in
as far as like churches and individuals
and businesses that are giving to us to
support this Mission
um
how do I do that like is this something
I need to do through non-profit because
it's just my wife and I and uh my one
child uh so it's not like a big
Corporation or a big you know nothing
big really but I don't really know how
to do it as far as the taxes and stuff
goes and at the same time I want the
people that are supporting us to have as
much benefit as possible as well you
know in regards to tax write-offs and
stuff like that
well love your heart brother very cool
you're good you're a good man and so it
it is a fairly simple process but it's
going to take a little bit of time and a
little bit of expense you set up a 501c3
non-profit and uh that non-profit then
becomes tax deductible for anyone that
donates to it
uh you'll have to find you know you'll
establish an IRS number and that'll be
Associated given to each of your donors
uh that they then conduct that take the
tax write-off a non-profit does not mean
um
that uh uh no monies coming in it
doesn't mean that not enough money is
coming in it is a simple accounting
entry
that shows that the owner of the
business is not taking the money home
for X as excess profit it's all it is
okay so my point being this a non-profit
has to techn has to physically be
profitable
or you go home okay meaning you have to
bring in more than you take out if you
need 40 000 and you bring in thirty
thousand you're a non-profit but you're
going out of business right
right so non-profits have to be from a
cash standpoint actually profitable
so you have to bring in more than goes
out but it's an accounting entry with
the IRS that shows that the profits are
being used for the benefit of the
ministry which includes feeding you and
your wife and it's not four hundred
thousand dollars a year of income for
the two of you although that's
technically okay uh it would be
suspicious to your donors uh but but
it's forty thousand and um and you know
just as a practical uh thing Ramsey
Family Foundation we've got friends that
do some of the things that you do and
they are some of the people that we
donate to from time to time and as a
donor from the donor's side uh we love
seeing that the money is helping people
and so just some simple uh iPhone videos
sent back occasionally and a little bit
of a report on the finances showing that
um
uh you know you're you're living on
forty thousand dollars a year which even
in Latin America is certainly not a
living high on the hog right so uh you
know we see where the money's going we
see that the people are being helped the
results of our donation because we see
our donations as investments into those
people on the street that you're trying
to help and you're the vehicle by which
they get there that's how a donor thinks
okay and if you can keep that dollar
keep that donor relationship real clear
and have the IRS and it's a separate
bank account separate from your personal
checking and then you are allowed by the
charter of the non-profit to live out of
that to pay personal expenses out of
that because it this is a Ministry it's
a mission you're missionaries
okay and that'll be so in regards to
like spending money
um let's say uh because we're we're
trying to be really realistic as well
with
um I guess allowing time for ourselves
uh so for example let's say we went to a
local Carnival uh a couple days out of
the month or something to uh just have
like a family day for us to keep it to
keep things you're not required you're
allowed to live
a reasonable life out of this it's not
it's not a violation of law or it won't
lose your tax status or something like
that
where people get into trouble is more of
a PR thing than a legal thing when some
uh when some non-profit starts buying a
private jet that's when people go huh
you know that kind of stuff and you're
going to the Cardinals hardly on that
thing is but that's more of a PR than a
legal it's not technically illegal to
buy a private jet with a non-profit it's
nothing wrong with it uh but but it
blows the donor base up and it blows the
pr up right so
um and we've all read those stories you
know so uh in a non-profit setting
because I people like me we don't want
to donate to your private jet we want to
donate those people on the street that
you're helping and if you take your
family to the carnival in the process
we're not going to be angry about that
okay I'll see so in regards to us doing
those types of activities that's
completely normal
you would move money from the non-profit
into your personal account as your
personal income missionaries all do that
because missionaries all have to eat and
have electricity and gas in the bus
right the non-profit then at the end of
the year what do I do as far as taxes go
in regards to keeping up with how much I
move from that account into ours nothing
or nothing
your mission you're living on donations
oh okay I understand double double check
with your tax person and they can help
you walk through all of this matter of
fact if you hit the tax Pros on
ramseysolutions.com one of those in your
area you'll probably be able to guide
you through forming the non-profit it's
really not that difficult it just takes
a little bit of time it's not considered
income if he takes that shouldn't be I'm
sure I mean operations so yeah but uh
you know again double check that because
I'm wrong half the time on this stuff so
uh tax stuff I'm horrible at but I do
know the part about the non-profit
because we formed the Ramsey Family
Foundation we've got our own that we use
for as a as a methodology for our
family's generosity uh and philanthropy
and so
um but and so we have a 501c3 that does
not take donations from the outside
world we funded ourselves and so uh and
then that's how that's how we handle the
distribution of our giving is through
that and your sister Denise is the
director of that again so we kind of got
into all of that uh in detail even
though we're not on the mission field
now we don't I don't draw an income from
that foundation and I burnish the income
to the foundation so quite the opposite
so but that that's what you got to get
into and just learn about it but it's
really not really that tough there's no
not it's not complete rocket science
where you can't get your arms around it
you'll be able to figure it out and do
it hey man we love you appreciate what
you're doing that puts this hour of the
Ramsey Show in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you love this
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]